bonjour madame à birse merci d'être en
direct avec nous assure un rt france
alors la famine engendrés par le
coronavirus pourrait tuer plus que la
pandémie elle-même c'est un drame
oui en effet c'est un pandémie
silencieuse que cette pandémie de la fin
puisque le coronavirus n'est pas tant la
pandémie elle-même que les conséquences
socio-économiques impacts
socio-économiques sur les populations et
notamment on voit émerger les
populations la précarité de plus en plus
grande et la sécurité alimentaire de
plus en plus grande dans les populations
urbaines et périurbaines c'est le
nouveau phénomène entraînée par la crise
du coc vides et les restrictions socio
économiques qui sont liées à cette
pandémie
oui parce que l' ong oxfam a recensé en
fait dix foyers de farine de famine
extrême donc les pays en guerre comme le
yémen et la syrie
beaucoup de pays du continent africain
mais la nouveauté c'est qu'il ya des
pays comme l'inde l'afrique du sud le
brésil qui pourraient connaître des
situations dramatiques
oui on voit que l'amérique latine c'est
là où on a une augmentation la plus
importante actuellement de la sécurité
alimentaire
alors quand on dit insécurité
alimentaire c'est à dire des gens qui
ont également des difficultés à se
nourrir qui vont souvent au lit le
ventre vide il faut bien séparer ce que
l'on appelle la sécurité alimentaire
chronique de la sécurité alimentaire
aiguë alors la sécurité alimentaire
aiguë c'est là où nous avons déjà des
conflits des chocs climatiques et tout
cela à cela se rajoute la crise du coc
vite donc on a un cocktail toxique qui
fait que dans les pays les plus touchés
par le déplacement par l'insécurité par
la violence par les conflits la
situation est dramatique et vont
s'ajouter maintenant des pays où on a
justement comme l'inde comme l'amérique
latine
des situations qui sont en fait liés aux
restrictions et aux interruptions ou
ralentissement de la chaîne alimentaire
ce qui fait les gens les plus pauvres
ont deux
ils ont plus de difficultés à pouvoir
acheter leur repas nourrir leur famille
on voit les travailleurs qui travaillent
les ouvriers qui travaillent les
journaliers qui travaillait au jour le
jour ce délire se lève le matin ont un
travail et nourrissent leurs familles le
soin avec ce qu'ils ont gagné en raison
justement des restrictions et des
confinement ces personnes ne peuvent
plus aller travailler
donc ils ne peuvent plus nourrir leur
famille c'est ça qui nous inquiète le
plus actuellement alors il y avait un
objectif qui avait été établi par l'onu
en 2015 c'était éradiquer la faim dans
le monde à partir de 2030
on en est loin gens me dire qu on recule
on en est loin en effet 680 millions de
personnes en 2020 souffrent d'insécurité
alimentaire chronique c'est à dire 'ne
ont du mal à se nourrir sont en état de
sous alimentation
mais là avec le co vide et si la
tendance se poursuit on a depuis cinq
ans une augmentation de 60 millions de
personnes qui sont dans ce cas
donc s'il a la tendance continue
malheureusement
en 2030 on arrivera à 840 millions de
personnes qui ont des difficultés à se
nourrir et à trouver de quoi faire le
repas et les enfants sont les plus
touchés
c'est 340 millions d'enfants dans le
monde qui souffrent de retards de
croissance et ce qui manque justement de
nutriments essentiels pour cette
croissance s'est peut-être sept
générations futures qui qu'il faut
atteindre maintenant qu'il faut aider
maintenant et le programme alimentaire
mondial s'est fixé comme objectif
d'aider 138 millions de personnes en
2020 jusqu'à la fin de cette année et de
l'est d'aider ceux qui ont le plus de
difficultés à se nourrir alors pour
régler pour faire un pull est en tout
cas la faim dans le monde
quelques pistes un règlement des
conflits effacement des dettes en des
pays touchés par la famine
on en est où justement là-dessus alors
nous travaillons avec les gouvernements
bien sûr que dans les 83 pays où le
programme alimentaire intervient pour
essayer justement de les aider à
développer le filet de sécurité sociale
les programmes de prévention sociale
pour aider les familles des familles en
difficulté on aide également les
gouvernements à mettre en place des
programmes de cantines scolaires ou
d'alimentation scolaire des programmes
de prévention de la malnutrition pour
les femmes allaitantes les mamans et
également les enfants de moins de cinq
ans donc tous ces programmes est
également si vous voulez nous
privilégions maintenant le transfert
d'assistance en cash en liquide ou par
une carte électronique comme tous les
réfugiés syriens et bien cela permet de
donner un pouvoir d'achat à ces familles
et quand la nourriture est disponible
sur les marchés quand la chaîne
alimentaire n'est pas interrompue et
qu'il y a de quoi se nourrir sur les
marchés et bien les familles vont
pouvoir acheter des oeufs des produits
frais des légumes
ce sont ces produits à haute teneur
nutritionnelle qui sont les plus chers
et qui en fait sont le moins disponibles
pour ces familles les plus pauvres
est ce que vous avez peut-être un peu
d'espoir peut-être vous voyez une issue
à cette crise alimentaire dans le monde
actuellement la situation est très
préoccupante l'aide des bailleurs de
fonds est nécessaire car les
financements pour les organisations
venues ou pour les ong qui sont nos
partenaires sont essentiels donc on nous
en faisons nous faisons appel aux
bailleurs de fonds le pam pour vous
donner une idée a besoin de 4,9
milliards de dollars pour terminer ses
programmes en 2020 c'est à dire que dans
six mois nous serons à noël et il faut
que
nous puissions rassembler ses 4,9
milliards c'est une somme énorme et ce
sont bien sûr les bailleurs de fonds les
gouvernements qui doivent venir à notre
aide
on le voit on voit que c'est essentiel
au yémen on voit que c'est essentiel
dans des dans les pays africains
également qu'il faut aider et avec ces
nouveaux pays émergents où la sécurité
alimentaire va commencer à devenir un
réel problème c'est-à-dire l'amérique
latine merci madame bière ça j'espère
que cet appel sera entendu je rappelle
que vous êtes porte parole du programme
alimentaire mondial merci d'avoir et en
direct avec